is Halloween substantially different in
Canada it actually is where I'm from
Vancouver it's like there are explosives
involved like every kid is just like and
it's Canada which is like really
pacifist country like not known for its
you know heavy arms or anything but on
Halloween it is it's dangerous yeah you
know what I mean like I remember when I
would leave for Halloween I get dressed
up as some you know it like cowboy or
something and I'll be walking out the
door I'll be looking at my parents
thinking like there's a fine line
between sending your kid out
trick-or-treating and just calling Child
Protective Services it was so dangerous
that the car would get bottle rockets in
the face really oh yes what is with them
I think it's because they're bottling up
so much pent-up hostility from being
nice all the time
I think so too in Halloween you get to
cover your face and suddenly it's like
die yeah excuse me may I purge you our
prime minister turns into a
[Laughter]
you